Germany has assumed a seat for two years
on the United Nations Security Council
what are your plans first of all we will
take an active role in managing the
crises and conflicts being handled by
the Security Council they include Syria
Yemen Ukraine and now Venezuela this is
an important task and it's clear that
people have expectations of us we're
expected to take responsibility and
that's something we want to do from that
there are important topics of her own
that we would like to put to the
Security Council's climate and security
is one of those issues that is not
getting enough attention and the
connection between climate change and
security issues is becoming increasingly
important change we want to put the role
and experience of women and war higher
on the agenda there is much to do the
United Nations is doing a lot already
but we have to do even more because we
are often the first to suffer in
conflict and women often have special
skills that can help settle these
conflicts later on Unitarian law and
humanitarian aid is also important to us
many died trying to help others we have
to change that and change the legal
framework issue though is disarmament
this is also an issue that has to be
discussed with the global community as
you can see we have many initiatives and
talking points that are important to us
and which the Security Council will have
to consider the United States and Russia
are at odds over many issues at the
moment it is said that the Security
Council's ability to act is therefore
limited you've just met the foreign
ministers of both countries what role
can Germany play we don't want to
pretend to be more important than we
really are
but I have spoken with foreign minister
Lavrov in Moscow as well as with
Secretary of State Pompeo in Washington
there are issues that are not only of
interest to the US and Russia such as
the future of the INF treaty wherever we
can help to create an understanding
between them we are happy to do so but
it's not just about Russia and the US
China also has a part to play in the
issue of disarmament and will be very
active over the coming
excellence in this regard angers yet an
incumbent 499 article change is
happening in Venezuela Germany and the
EU haven't recognized the new
self-proclaimed acting president can
Germany afford to be neutral in Tunisia
we are not neutral we are on one Cueto
side because it's difficult for us to
recognize the legitimacy of Honduras
reelection it's obvious that there were
so many irregularities in the election
that we can only speak to a limited
degree of a democratic election that's
why we are calling for fresh elections
for the National Assembly to assume
responsibility and for constitutional
law to be restored in Venezuela we have
made that note together with our
European partners that's going to be our
policy over the coming days
and I expect that this will be made very
clear Nikita for knows that says oh no
zio Italy she had good visit we are not
neutral
we support the COI who is doing good
thank you for the interview you're
welcome
you